uh meanwhile cnn they don't have a lot
of fans they're starting to cover the
freedom convoy in canada here's how they
decided to frame it though watch
emergency in place in ottawa where the
police chief says covet protests are a
quote nationwide insurrection driven by
madness just think of the language i
know it sounds familiar to you right a
threat to democracy an insurrection
sedition prime minister justin trudeau
remains in isolation he calls these a
fringe minority
here to react fox news contributor joe
koncha joe this trucker protest is kind
of like a tale of two narratives you
heard the cnn narrative and there have
been 20 arrests and there are
investigations into hate crimes but then
when you hear from the truckers
themselves and their supporters who are
on the ground they say that the legacy
media is purposefully uh trying to paint
them in a negative light so what is
really going on here and what should we
believe
wow i i watched that report and at one
point they described uh the trucker
convoy and the fact that the protests
are expanding uh they compared
compared to the macovid said they're
like a contagion like covid uh then they
use the words and they're loaded words
like sedition and insurrection i'm
pretty sure i've heard those words used
a lot in these parts lately so when they
start to apply this sort of hyperbole
it's impossible to take this sort of
reporting seriously anymore because
clearly they went in with a
predetermined narrative they went in to
take a side in these situations yes
there have been 20 arrests most of them
have been for very small things
when you compare it to say the black
lives matter protests of 2020 in the
summer of love and and the hundreds upon
hundreds of arrests and officers being
hurt and and property being damaged to
the tune of billions and you had cnn
saying that they were mostly peaceful
protests that tells you that again this
is not a news network they are an
activist partisan organization and now
they've apparently expanded
that sort of reportage north of the
border carly the video that we just
showed showed people playing street
hockey and let me tell you if street
hockey means insurrection and sedition
i'm going to jail immediately after the
show for stuff that i did in my teens
i'm in a lot of trouble uh meantime joe
kamala harris's staffers say she is a
bully who destroys their souls but the
l.a times says ah the mass exit is from
her office it's just her way of making
some changes new people are going to
come in we know that but will anything
change so long as kamala is still a vp
she's not making the changes because
people are leaving on their own it's not
like kamala has gone full trump and just
started firing people left and right
because she thinks they're doing a bad
job and therefore we need to change of
course uh people are willingly believing
on their own volition uh and not just
one or two but many uh look this is a
vice president that is currently polling
in the 30s as far as approval when was
the last time we've really seen her you
know they tried to get her out after the
new year as far as interviews and those
were profound disasters so now she's
being re-hidden again uh look there's
buyer's remorse around this vice
presidential pick no question she was
supposed to be plan b that if joe biden
doesn't run in 2024
he hands the baton off to her and off
they go and instead you hear talk about
her either being replaced or the fact
that she will not be the nominee if joe
biden does not run either way things
have not gone well for kamala harris in
her first year there's no reason to
believe given her performance handling
the border given her performance on
voting rights and so on that it's going
to get any better in 2022. by the way
guys i i have to say to the spotify
people i'm sorry to the rumble people i
know they're offering joe rogan the
other joe 100 million dollars i am
willing to say right now on national
television that this joe who has worked
in radio before will take one percent of
that one percent one and be very very
happy and get you the big listeners that
you need a million will be more than
fine with me guys
he'll he'll go full dr evil there he is
going full dr evil
rumble pay the man throw me a freaking
bone here you get joe concha freaking
bone
joe does that make you discount joe just
count joe
should that be your new nickname
discount joe no tommy tuesday i'm the
fourth most powerful joe in the country
guys it goes it goes uh joe manchin joe
burrow joe biden joe rogan than me i
guess that makes me the fifth there you
go
still only on one hand so we'll take it
joe thank you so much hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now